so apparently the gravity battery is
back in the spotlight i've seen news
articles about it pop up recently and
now it's time to stop the script before
things get out of hand this will be
short and sweet but if you want a more
detailed take you can check out
thunderfur's video link in the
description
so what is the problem with this thing
in energy production especially with
renewables we have periods of energy
surplus and energy deficit you need to
put surplus power somewhere so you can
use it during your deficit but how do
you store all that power do you build a
giant battery yes and no this is where
the gravity battery comes in in this
case called energy vault the concept
itself sounds reasonable you have a
bunch of cranes in the middle with
concrete blocks lying around when you
have surplus energy you use it to stack
the blocks when you have an energy
deficit you lower them down and spin a
generator in the process here's their
promotional video where the ceo talks
about saving the world while stock music
plays in the bank how to solve one of
the largest global problems facing our
planet today
how to store renewable energy in both an
economical and sustainable way cemex's
solution eliminated the transportation
sector so we could end the world's
reliance on robert piconi the ceo of
energy vault
all right so why is this incredibly
stupid first off the blocks there are
about 10 000 of them on this picture
let's assume each one is about 20 cubic
meters based on how big the ones were in
their promotional video that's 200 000
cubic meters of concrete producing one
cubic meter of concrete takes 0.41
tonnes of co2 to make this entire thing
you're looking at 82 000 tons of co2
emitted into the atmosphere neat there
are ways to produce bricks in an
environmentally friendly way though as
they show us in their video but this
would not be an option everywhere plus
they look like they would fall apart
much sooner also have you heard about
this thing called wind on most of that
promotional cgi the thing is next to
wind power plants places where winds are
strong in that place you have a giant
six-sided crane with some very long
wires and you'll be trying to stack
blocks with high precision i see now
this is where the proponents of this
project would say the software software
will handle it is detectable equivalent
of i have faith in jesus the energy
vault also comes with a 30 to 40 year
warranty i would assume even shorter
since that would be thirty to four years
of banging blocks together according to
the website the thing has the capacity
for 35 megawatt hours so a single three
megawatt wind turbine operating at say
25 on average for a whole day that's 18
megawatt hours now i'm no engineer but
if i understand it correctly one giant
tower of concrete can almost store the
daily output of two wind turbines nice
so this design clearly has a lot of
issues that need resolving so let's do
it first off the wind problem how do we
stop the wind from blowing us around
forget that stupid six armed crane
design and use a giant gantry crane
instead it's far more stable than a
regular crane alright so we now have a
stable crane but we haven't solved the
wind problem completely the wires are
still affected so instead of having this
thing on the surface let's dig a hole
for it there we go with this we solved
the wind problem this also solved the
second problem capacity digging a huge
bit below the gantry lets you stack
blocks much higher and thus store more
power how come you people never thought
of this seriously why even have a
regular crane arranging things in a
circular formation why not a gantry with
a square formation it's not because the
circular design looks very futuristic on
the cgi right it's it's not that right
the third problem is the blocks they are
subject to damage and erosion and need
to be replaced eventually we could solve
this if we had a material which doesn't
break or erode this is the point where
elon musk would say this is synthetic
self-fixing hyper diamonds and i say
water so why don't we just fill our big
hole with water put some water tanks on
the gantry and pump the water up when we
have an energy surplus and let it down
through a turbine when we have a deficit
come to think of it what if we just dug
a hole somewhere higher and let the
water down from there that way we don't
need gantries or water tanks let's call
this new invention pumped storage
hydroelectricity
there we go we revolutionized energy
storage i guess congratulations thank
you for watching please don't forget to
like and subscribe and i also have a
patreon if you think this content is
worth your money and i'll be seeing you
next time